bonjour à tous bienvenue pour un
parlement hebdo exceptionnel kathia
gilder 2 est à mes côtés aujourd'hui
beaucoup parler évidemment de ce
référendum britannique et oui mickaël
deux invités sont avec nous pour
commenter ce choix britannique
historique aux conséquences majeures
françois de rugy bonjour genre député
écologiste de loire-atlantique membres
du groupe ces socialistes écologistes et
républicains l'assemblée et jean arthuis
bonjour bonjour député européen membre
de l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe
ils ont donc choisi à 51 20 9% les
britanniques se sont prononcés pour
sortir de l'union européenne à votre
historique comme nous le rappelle
nathalie guille war très tôt ce matin ni
djelfa rage farouches partisans du camp
du breakbeat entre en scène sous les
applaudissements
la nouvelle vient de tomber le brésil
gagne à 51,9 % la grande-bretagne sorte
de l'union européenne ni djelfa rage a
réussi son pari et crie pas victoire
il faut un gouvernement de briques si il
faut que les costumes négociations
commencent le véhicule rapidement
possible il faut commencer à penser de
façon la guerre mondiale à notre avenir
et ce qui doit se passer maintenant
c'est que le 23 juin avoir bac fournit
un jour férié national
on l'appellera
cris de joie applaudissements de ses
militants réunis dans ce qg à londres
dans le camp du riz men c'est une tout
autre ambiance les militants sont
effondrés les jeux sont faits et le
royaume uni à voter pour sa sortie de
l'union européenne
la participation a été très important
plus de 70% de la population à voter
c'est une nuit historique pour la grande
bretagne
la victoire des partisans du brésil
constitue un tournant majeur dans
l'histoire de l'union européenne
voilà parlement hebdo spéciales dont
consacré aux conséquences de ce vote
britannique on viendra dans un deuxième
temps sur le reste de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire
une question avoue françois de rugy vous
vous êtes réveillés comment ce matin ce
que vous vous attendiez à ce vote
je crois que malheureusement le voyez
venir pas simplement depuis quelques
heures mais depuis des mois on craignait
ce résultat et du jour d'ailleurs où
david cameron a décidé avant les
élections législatives britanniques un
an de dire de toute façon il y aura un
référendum je vais renégocier les
conditions d'appartenance de la grande
bretagne à l'union européenne il avait
obtenu d'ailleurs des dérogations qui
que pour ma part je considérais comme
anormal et malgré cela le peuple
britannique dans sa majorité a voté la
sortie de l'union européenne donc c'est
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
profond que simplement la politique
européenne du moment vont revenir
là-dessus genre tu es ce que c'est la
fin du rêve refaire non ce début
certainement pas l europe était enlisé
sans gouvernement
sans projet empêtrée dans des procédures
administratives qui font que lorsque un
citoyen européen une collectivité
territoriale un acteur économique
sollicite l'union européenne faut alors
prendre des intermédiaires pour remplir
des dossiers dont l'épaisseur est un
défi à la raison est bien mais l'action
après ce référendum on dit que les
britanniques changer tout a basculé que
l'europe se finit les bris ce que
soutient toujours spécialement par les
britanniques étaient dans une ambiguïté
total ils voulaient le marché intérieur
mais ils voulaient garder leur monnaie
autrement dit un marché unique mais avec
plusieurs monnaies
l'argent de ce qu'elle est en
contradiction totale pour vous c'est la
conclusion logique d'un très long
divorce entamée il ya longtemps en tout
cas je seul détail qui n'avait jamais
vraiment intégré le projet dirigeants
européens vont devoir cesser de prendre
pour excuse
les blocages de l'union européenne il va
falloir que les européens sache s'ils
veulent que l'europe dans une
mondialisation qui est devenu si
inquiétante
on peut on est à la merci d'un tsunami
financier ou dégradations des climats
migration qu'elle est
quel est l'état qui à lui seul pourrait
participer à l'organisation du monde
pour prévenir force de noël danger
l'accident le rôle on sait la
clarification aujourd'hui c'est une
clarification qui se fait dans la
douleur parce qu'il faut quand même le
dire
moi j'ai toujours été pro européen et
j'ai toujours été sceptique sur la
volonté des britanniques de participer
vraiment c'était une vraie fausse
participation à l'union européenne le
marché unique oui mais l'union
européenne
en gros il voulait bien les bénéfices
des droits que ça donne mais pas les
devoirs pas la solidarité et ce qu'ils
avaient négocié c'était encore un recul
dans la solidarité
pour autant c'est une des principales
nations européennes population en
produit intérieur brut un économie donc
c'est quand même un recul inédit dans la
construction européenne que pour la
première fois un grand état d'avoir
c'est la première fois qu'un état sort
de l'union européenne et qui en plus est
un grand état qui le décide alors
justement david cameron a pris acte de
ce résultat lui même qui avait organisé
ce référendum britannique il s'est
exprimé tout à l'heure sur le thème
dance to et écouter les britanniques ont
pris une décision très claire de prendre
un chemin différent et de ce résultat
je pense que le pays a besoin d'un
nouveau leader pour prendre ces
directions
je ferai tout ce que je peux en tant que
premier ministre pour stabiliser le
navire au cours des prochaines semaines
et des prochains mois mais je ne pense
pas que ce serait bien pour moi
d'essayer d'être le capitaine qui
dirigent notre pays vers sa prochaine
destination
il ne sera pas le capitaine qui va
diriger ce bateau at il dit jean arthuis
est ce que pour vous le discours david
cameron est clair qu'est ce qu'il va
faire maintenant il est resté ambigu
on entre dans une période d'incertitude
c'est sans précédent la fois l'art
négoce
et la grande bretagne n'est quand même
pas si éloignés géographiquement de
l'union européenne donc il va bien
falloir trouver des accords pour ma d
une collaboration données et choisi là
c'est que l'union européenne doit être
ferme avec les britanniques
écoutez s'accorder au mois de février
lorsque monsieur k - là du bas voilà
j'ai un référendum
chers collègues parce que c'est un peu
ça l'europe ce sont des petits
arrangements entre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement et comme il y en a toujours
un qui est à la veille d'une élection
ses camarades font preuve d'une grande
complaisance mutuelle et ben oui on va
s'arranger ça alors tu veux pas
d'intégration politique
on va dire que rappaz d'intégration
politique tu veux garder ta moan et
avait très bien tu gardes ta monnaie tu
veux des arrangements sur le plan social
pour ne pas prendre en charge les
allocations familiales de ceux qui
viennent d'europe de l'est on va être
d'accord là dessus vous ça s'est fini
c'est franchement oui parce que il faut
que l'europe cesse d'être une espèce de
colloques clandestins entre les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement entre les
ministres prenez prenez le scandale de
révélée par luc slicks par panama
peppers voilà une question qui intéresse
les citoyens européens et bien qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il sait pas c'est qu'il
ya tout juste une semaine
les ministres des finances se sont
réunis et trouver un accord pour
l'évitement de du non paiement de
l'impôt mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
savent ils ont trouvé des petits
arrangements alors que ça devrait être
sur la place publique
l'europe d'européens françois d'origine
notamment jean arthuis deux mois qu'est
ce qu'on va faire françois hollande va
réunir aujourd'hui conseil des ministres
exceptionnel divali voir angela merkel
qu'est ce qu'on fait les nouveaux
traités qu'est-ce qu'on négocie
c'est quoi ces fossati françois un
langage clair vis-à-vis de la
grande-bretagne et du futur premier
ministre britannique
c'est à dire que maintenant c'est la
sortie de l'union européenne c'est pas
il à moi je pense qu'il faut pas se dire
ah ben finalement il ya eu un vote
populaire massif pour la sortie de
l'union européenne mais en fait ils vont
y rester d'une certaine façon en cas de
droit mais il serait de fait ça il n'en
n'est pas question parce que ça ce
serait le signe que d'autres états
demanderait la même chose dans les mois
ou deux pour un truc de musées la veille
françois hollande qui avait fait toute
cette campagne sur la renégociation du
traité et
pas du tout pareil là eu un vote et puis
l'autre point le premier ministre
britannique a démissionné est ce que le
président de la commission européenne ne
devrait pas démissionner s'il demandé
aujourd'hui à moi je pense que la
question allait poser et que monsieur
juncker devrait clairement d'avoir
s'exprimer et remettre son mandat de
président de la commission en jeu c'est
lui qui mène cette europe en effet des
petits arrangements il est le fruit
d'ailleurs 17 europe de petits
arrangements entre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement fathi ben pas grand chose
parce que la commission n'est pas un
gouvernement
le problème de l'europe c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de gouvernement il n'y a pas de
pilote dans l'avion
donc on s'en remet aux circonstances et
les chefs d'états et de gouvernements
essaient de prolonger l'illusion qu'ils
ont encore en mains leurs prérogatives
de souveraineté moyennant quoi il donne
en spectacle lors impuissance politique
et c'est ça qui fait le demander c'est
la peau la démission de jean claude
juncker pour eux non je souhaite je
souhaite je souhaite mesurer qu'on ouvre
une convention à et que on associe les
citoyens européens à ce que peut être un
projet pour l'europe
à l'heure de la globalisation le repli
sur soi est une impasse absolue et une
constitution par le passé on a vu ce que
ça oui mais elle avait été fait du
maître et technocratique très
bureaucratique l'europe aujourd'hui et
fille est piloté par qui par les
diplomates par le coreper c'est à dire
les représentants des états membres les
chefs des tables une pause au niveau
européen c'est la thèse de certains il
faut s'arrête il faut regarder ce qui a
fonctionné
il faut il faut faire le bilan il ya des
situations qui ne peuvent pas attendre
l'émigration par exemple faute d'une
diplomatie commune faute de capacité
militaire commune des européens sont
allés en ordre dispersé en irak en libye
en syrie
ils ont allumé la mèche et et se sont
retirés
la phase suivante c'est quoi c'est la
disparition des étages sont
l'immigration qu'elle convienne à calais
par exemple calais oui les migros comme
l'a dit emmanuel macron attendant le
times faire attention aux propos
définitifs mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
à brive au négoce non monsieur cameron
et à son successeur parce que ce sera
son successeur doit savoir que tout va
être négocié
et maintenant c'est pas pour rien
d'ailleurs que les irlandais du nord ont
voté contre ce brixi
et vraiment routière au milieu de
l'irlande l'irlande va de nouveau être
coupée en deux urgent il existe des
accords qui s'appelle accorde du touquet
qui ont été négociées à propos justement
de calais de cette frontière est et ce
qu'on fait est mis en cause mais ils
vont mettre l'argent cause c'est évident
mais c'est évident et d'ailleurs c'est
une heure de vérité parce que là aussi
la grande bretagne ne jouaient pas le
jeu
elle n'était pas dans schengen etc mais
ce que je veux dire qui me paraît très
important il détient une pause
de fait une pause de toute façon depuis
dix ans l'échec de du traité
constitutionnel européen dont la france
ailleurs pendant une responsabilité
puisque la france avait majoritairement
voté non et bien on n'a jamais réussi à
retrouver ni un nouveau projet je pense
qu'une conscience et plus du tout à
l'ordre du jour malheureusement il faut
quelques projets concrets gratuit vous
le savez un nombre d'états beaucoup
moins nombreux si on doit toujours être
27 puisque maintenant ce serait 27
on n'y arrivera pas c'est l'occasion
d'un sursaut aussi pour l'europe ce vote
est évidemment ça peut être une chance
de se roder paul henri spaak disait du
temps du général de gaulle
si vous ne voulez pas d'intégration
alors il faut prendre les britanniques
si vous voulez l'intégration il faut pas
les britanniques n'ont donc la situation
est claire
ou bien l'europe n'est qu'un marché
ouverte au monde
ou bien l'europe a une vocation et et
l'europe de revenir dans l'histoire et
donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut ouvrir
cette convention associer les citoyens
parce que il n'y aura pas d'europe forte
sans démocratie arthuis et françois de
rugy vous d'imaginer qu'il ya eu de
nombreuses réactions politiques
depuis ce matin je vous propose
d'écouter quelques extras revient
évidemment pour en discuter
c'est une victoire de la démocratie il
ya eu une pression incroyable comme en
2005 en france et on s'aperçoit que les
peuples sont encore bien vivants qu'ils
ont compris qu'on pouvait pas être libre
à moitié que c'est un moyen essentiel de
régler ses propres problèmes parce que
chaque peuple doit régler ses propres
problèmes en avoir les moyens
et puis c'est un enjeu aussi parce que
moi je ne suis pas contre l'europe
c'est un enjeu de reconstruire une
europe des nations libres et une onde de
choc terrible pour la grande bretagne
on va voir pourquoi et qui va
naturellement se propager en europe et
c'est une onde de choc qui appelle
des réactions d'hommes d'état pas de
gens qui veulent suivre l'opinion et les
gens qui regardant les choses en face
propose un chemin et un projet mais ça
n'est pas un petit événement ça n'est
pas un événement britannique c'est un
événement d'importance
continental est peut-être mondiale parce
que les soubresauts sur l'économie vont
elles très important est-ce qu'on
assiste ce matin à la fin du rêve
européen
peut-être pas à la fin du rêve européen
qui subsistera et devra subsister dans
l'avenir c'est nous voulons garder notre
identité européenne mais en tout cas à
un choc à un réveil pour ceux qui
dormaient à un moment événement que
l'histoire retiendra c'est un mauvais
jour pour le rêve européen l'europe
françois de rugy ça va être redevenir au
coeur de cette future campagne de 2007
on en avait pas beaucoup parlé jusque là
oui ce qui était une erreur d'ailleurs
parce que moi je partage de ce point de
vue ce qu'a dit jean arthuis tout à
l'heure
l'avenir d'un pays comme la france c'est
de s'inscrire dans une construction
européenne qui nous donne beaucoup plus
de moyens qu'en restant tout seul dans
notre coin derrière les britanniques
vont vite le découvrir à leurs dépens
que ça va pas favoriser les jean luc
mélenchon marine le pen nicolas dupont
aignan qu'on écoutait tout à l'heure
mais ils vont sans doute se déchaîner là
on le voit bien
j'ai l'impression comme vous dites mais
madame le pen évidemment on va demander
la même chose en france
monsieur mélenchon j'ai l'impression que
dans le fond c'est aussi ce qu'il
souhaite j'ai même vu arnaud montebourg
dire pourquoi pas un référendum il ya
trois jours le merde
donc il va y avoir une clarification
aussi dans le débat politique français
sur comment les uns et les autres se
positionne par rapport à la
participation ce que c'est ça qui est en
jeu la participation ou non à la
construction à peine quel projet
européen est ce qu'il faudra être
concret parce que honnêtement ce ne sera
pas des grands principes sur l'europe
des peuples europe des nations ça veut
rien dire il faut être concret avec les
français sur qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
ensemble au niveau européen et ce qu'on
veut se protéger du terrorisme ensemble
est-ce qu'on veut relever le défi
énergie climat ensemble voilà les
questions vous avez dit qu'il y avait
plus de capitaine à la tête du bateau
européen mais pas les oreilles ou à
passer le couple franco-allemand et
surtout est ce que maintenant à la
faveur de ces événements il va redevenir
un acteur central
elle espère la construction européenne
je l'espère mais encore faut-il que les
deux membres de ce couple soit dans une
position
disposant de la même autorité le bref de
la france aujourd'hui c'est que la
france s'est mise un peu en veilleuse
dans un corner donc n'attendons pas de
l'europe qu'elle accomplisse à la place
de la france les réformes que la france
tarde à accomplir en attendant il ya un
vrai risque d'éclatement de l'europe
parce que d'autres moi je crois pas je
vois pas si on va faire des réponses que
l'urgence et c'est la responsabilité des
politiques aller à la présidentielle
pour avoir un projet franco français ça
n'a pas de sens c'est une impasse
absolue nous sommes dans la
mondialisation
ce monde global inquiète la plupart de
nos concitoyens
or il y à des risques évidents sans une
once à lui dans cette mondialisation qui
va falloir organiser le monde qui peut
l'organiser sinon l'europe et tout le
reste c'est du baratin
c'est des histoires donc sortons de
partageant une vision
je pense que ce référendum doit être un
électrochoc pour les européens tels que
leur offre je suis au parlement européen
très franchement on a un budget qui
n'est pas un budget et qui est de 1% du
produit intérieur brut européen qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec ça et ce budget
est enfermé dans un cadre pluriannuel de
7 ans lorsque survient une crise la
crise des migrations
on n'a pas de moyens et aux deux hommes
monde et aux concitoyens l'image de
l'impuissance
il a fallu des drames en méditerranée
pour que les européens se demande ce que
fait l'europe et l'europe n'a pas de
prérogatives parce que les états ont
gardé toutes leurs prérogatives en
matière de contrôle des migrations
ça fait des mois que l'on parle de
garde-côtes de garde-frontières mais il
ya toujours rien parce que chaque état
est enfermé dans son égoïsme national
l'europe est une addition d'égoïsmes
nationaux alors ça ne peut pas continuer
comme ça dort ici je vais vous ramener
sur un plan qui peut-être un petit peu
plus franco-français
il ya déjà eu un référendum en france
est un homme qui a été votée mais qui
n'a pas été appliquée dans les faits est
ce que cette fracture albane de la moi
je regrette qu'à l'époque moi j'étais
pour le oui mais je regrette qu'à
l'époque on n'est pas suivi l'idée qui
était défendu notamment par daniel cohn
bendit qui était qu'il y ait un
référendum dans toute l'europe
en même temps et qu'il y ait la double
majorité pour que cette constitution
soit adoptée c'est à dire la majorité
des citoyens européens et la majorité
des états européens et à ce moment là
les états qui aurait dit non on aurait
pu les mettre devant leurs
responsabilités est ce que vous voulez
continuer à participer ou pas il ya eu
une ambiguïté en 2005
est-ce que c'était la participation à
l'union européenne où est ce que c'était
l'approbation de la constitution mais je
voudrais quand même dire qu'il ya à
peine un an on l'a oublié
on a sauvé la grèce mais on a surtout
empêcher le grec cite parce qu'à
l'époque ce n'était pas le break site
dont on parlait ce n'était pas de la
grande bretagne at on parlé de sens bien
c'était la grèce et pourquoi on a réussi
à maintenir la grèce dans l'union
européenne
parce qu'on a joué le jeu de la
solidarité européenne et donc quand on
le fait ça marche
quelques mots quand même genre arthuis
sur la crise économique peut-être
envisageable quand on voit que les
bourses s'effondrent aujourd'hui ce que
vous imaginez cela possible
vous allez les bourses hier était à la
hausse il y avait des spéculations
manifestement qui ne traduisait pas la
réalité économique c'était des paris
étaient faits monsieur cameron a fait un
pari il avait un problème d'unité du
royaume et donc il s'est servi de
l'europe et du risée de son parti
elles sont pas rendus compte pour
essayer de régler ce problème en fait
c'est d'un détournement d'europe c'est
une trahison de l'europe
donc j'espère qu'on va en sortir et
qu'on va avoir une ambition pour
l'europe faire de l'europe une puissance
mondiale
merci beaucoup aujourd'hui d'avoir été
notre invité exceptionnel aussi pour
parler évidemment de ce référendum
français d'origine vous restez avec nous
parce qu'on va beaucoup parler également
de ce qui se passe dans votre camp à
gauche et notamment d'une primaire
passée
la droite mais celle de la gauche car
elle aura peut-être lieu certainement
lieu les explications avec jérôme rabier
c'est donc une primaire à minima
qu'organisera le ps un scrutin prévu les
22 et 29 janvier 2017 et décidé en
dernière minute
la faute aux autres partis de gauche qui
ont opposé leur refus selon la direction
socialiste
nous sommes obligés de faire une
primaire dans l'urgence pas de notre
fait mais nous ferons tout pour qu'elle
soit représentative
un scrutin qui colle parfaitement au
calendrier fixé par françois hollande
qui décidera en fin d'année de se
représenter ou non et qui pourrait lui
permettre de se re légitimer
dans ces conditions pas question pour
europe ecologie les verts le parti
communiste ou encore le parti de gauche
de participer à cette opération
il faut donc chercher au sein des
socialistes frondeurs pour trouver des
candidats
la sénatrice marie noëlle lienemann a
confirmé sa candidature tout comme
gérard filoche et l'ancien ministre
arnaud montebourg envisage aussi d'y
aller mais à certaines conditions
si c'est une primaire des citoyens c'est
à dire que tous les français peuvent
venir pas seulement les français qui
auraient une carte ou des français qui
se reconnaîtrait dans tel ou tel
appareil
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation benoît
hamon l'écologiste françois de rugy ou
un membre du prg pourrait également se
présenter
à défaut de séduire en dehors de la
gauche gouvernementale
cette primaire aiguise les ambitions
présidentielles françois d'origine ma
question est franche et directe
etes-vous officiellement candidat à
cette primaire oh je vais vous dire j'ai
déjà dit que j'étais pour la primaire
avant que jean christophe cambadélis la
relance c'est une bonne surprise c'est
une surprise mais c'est une bonne
surprise
j'ai déjà dit que je l'envisageais je
n'annonce pas une candidature là sur
votre plateau parce que ça et c'est
quelque chose c'est un engagement fort
qu'ils méritent évidemment quelques
réflexions quelques discussions mais je
crois extrêmement important que
l'écologie soit représentée dans cette
primaire elle ne l'était pas il y a cinq
ans alors je vous mettais les empêche
pas d'être candidat aux bouffes là on
rentre dans des considérations non c'est
surtout qu'il faut se donner les moyens
d'être candidat dans de bonnes
conditions
mais c'est évident que c'est une une
hypothèse que j'envisage avec beaucoup
de détermination parce que je crois
encore une fois qu'il faut que
l'écologie soit présente dans cette
crise
écologie soit présente dans cette
primaire que cette primaire elle soit
ouverte et pour qu'elle soit ouverte
il faut pas que ce soit simplement entre
social vous êtes vraiment prêts à
participer à cette primaire qui
s'annonce comme une compétition ouverte
au président sortant oui d'ailleurs il a
été dit est ce qu'elle va avoir lieu
elle aura lieu
maintenant il n'y a plus d'hésitation il
ya eu des hésitations pendant plusieurs
mois et vous il aura lieu maintenant et
vous même dit son accord est donné c'est
pas une primaire avec un seul candidat
sinon c'est plus une primaire donc on
voit bien qu arnaud montebourg sera sans
doute candidat et je pense d'ailleurs
qu'il y aura la gauche contestataire on
va dire qu'il n'a cessé de s'opposer
pendant quatre ans va avoir un ou
plusieurs candidats peut-être monsieur
hamon et puis les radicaux de gauche qui
avait déjà participé il ya cinq ans leur
feront sans doute et les écologistes et
ce sera une nouveauté seront présents
françois de rugy être candidat face à
françois hollande parce que ça veut dire
que vous ne soutenez pas françois
hollande
mais ça veut dire ce que je dis depuis
des mois c'est à dire moi je fais preuve
d'une grande constance en la matière je
pense que il faut avoir une candidature
de rassemblement au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle parce que s'il
n'y a pas de rassemblement l'enjeu c'est
l'auto élimination de la gauche et des
écologistes et un deuxième tour polarisé
entre la droite et l'extrême droite
et c'est pas un fantasme regardez ce qui
s'est passé en autriche
regardez ce qui se passe dans beaucoup
de pays d'europe et même au delà
et puis en même temps cette candidature
de rassemblement on voit bien qu'elle ne
se décrète pas elle ne s'impose pas
d'elle-même de plus et donc il y a il
n'y a pas un rassemblement en effet
hautement malkin mais plus c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça et ça a été la même
chose aux régionales oui ce n'est pas le
président qui était en cause des
élections régionales il y avait menacé
le leader régional et donc il faut avoir
ce processus de débats parfois même de
confrontation parce qu'il ya des
divergences politiques et tranchée par
les citoyens tranche et ça aussi c'est
nouveau en répétition c'est des citoyens
quand est-ce que vous prendrez cette
décision oh non je pense que les choses
vont se décanter très rapidement sexe
très rapidement c'est à dire en voyez
bien que les impôts devront se
positionner soit et vous vous était
soulagé après c'est ça le calendrier
vous attendez quoi amoureux si vous
voulez c'est juste une question
d'organisation d'accord parce que bon
mais parce que c'est quelque chose de
sérieux sont pas c'est pas chacun se
présente maintenant mais parce que vous
avez vus à droite on
si un candidat par semaine et on sait
bien qu'il ya tout un tas qui n'iront
pas au bout moi si je me présente c'est
pour aller au bout c'est pour défendre
les idées écologistes jusqu'au bout du
débat de la primaire
eh ben je vous emmène justement sur le
terrain de l'écologie cette semaine
collègues députés ont voté le projet de
loi sur la biodiversité en nouvelle
lecture ils ont notamment interdit les
néonicotinoïdes ces insectes icipe tueur
d'abeilles
ils ont en revanche renoncé à surtaxer
l'huile de palme stéphanie des pierres
les députés l'avait validée en
commission pourtant hier soir ils n'ont
pas voté la surtaxation de l'huile de
palme
une marche arrière face aux pressions de
l'indonésie et de la malaisie
deux des plus grands producteurs de
palme de la planète dans l'hémicycle
delphine batho dénonce une victoire des
lobbys nous légiférons d'un certain
point de vue avec le couteau sous la
gorge et ce serait la grandeur de la
démocratie dans ce genre de
circonstances de le dire clairement un
chantage qu'un député de droite avaient
clairement explicité quelques minutes
plus tôt en indonésie ce sont des
contrats pour de plus de 250 avions
airbus qui sont en négociation je crois
que nous avons également des contrats en
matière de céréales qui sont en jeu il
n'y aura donc pas de surtaxation de
l'huile de palme en tout cas pas tout de
suite
à travers un amendement voté celui là
barbara pompili la ministre chargée de
la biodiversité s'est engagé à revoir la
fiscalité de toutes les huiles
alimentaires 10 6 6 mois selon la
rapporteure de la loi la majorité des
députés ne voulait plus d'une taxation
sur la palme l'amendement du
gouvernement serait donc un moindre mal
moi ce que j'ai essayé de faire c'est de
maintenir absolument quelque chose sur
l'huile de palme dans le texte sinon on
n'aurait rien eu
alan là s'était enterré et enterré ad
vitam aeternam enterrés ou pas réponse à
l'automne lors du budget les députés
devrait largement s'inspirer d'un
rapport présenté hier et qui propose de
remettre à plat toutes les taxes sur les
huiles alimentaires
ce sera la quatrième fois depuis 2002
que les parlementaires débattront mais
de la surtaxation de l'huile de palme
on a attendu la rapportant ce texte et
j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu mais je voulais
au moins qu'il ya une disposition
préserver le maximum sur sur cette taxe
finalement comme le
delphine batho vous légiférez une fois
de plus sous la pression des lobbys ah
bah ça on découvre pas quand on fait la
politique est un qui a des lobbys mais
c'est pas qu'une histoire de loup c'est
aussi une histoire de diplomatie entre
la france et l'indonésie avec beaucoup
d'autres enjeux bien variés que la
question de commandes d'airbus et ça
c'est la vie c'est pas simplement la vie
politique c'est la vie dans la vie il
n'ya pas des choses toutes simples comme
ça on appuie sur un bouton on fonce tout
droit et puis tout se réalise comme on
voudrait on est toujours en négociation
avec plusieurs choses à prendre en
compte au vert parce que je vais devenir
plutôt que la fois en termes de méthode
cette loi sur la biodiversité c'est une
avancée très importante dans beaucoup de
domaines et voilà qu'un jour un
amendement au sénat
désolé de le dire a été voté de façon
totalement impréparé on proposait de
multiplier la taxation par 20 aucun
autre domaine on propose ça aucune
réflexion d'ensemble sur la taxation des
18 l'alimentaire en général qui sont
toutes très différentes comme la
taxation des alcools en france on a des
tas de régime et du coup ça devient
l'anecdote parce que je suis désolé de
le dire à l'échelle du projet de loi
cette année qu de tic où on va s'occuper
dans un projet de loi sur la
biodiversité de la situation en
indonésie ou en malaisie
je pense que déjà si on s'occupe de la
biodiversité en france c'est déjà pas
mal et ensuite on a des discussions plus
globale qui intègre l'ensemble des
sujets et des huiles alimentaires et
l'ensemble des sujets avec le couvert de
roubles à bercy cet amendement non non
non non c'était au départ c'était un
amendement d'origine sénatoriale mais
c'est ses geôlières le droit
d'amendement il est totale et c'est très
bien à l'assemblée au sénat mais il faut
pas qu'on tombe dans le panneau
si vous voulez de mesures symboliques
l'incantatoire proclame at war et qui ne
sont ni préparés pour leur mise en
oeuvre et la globalité d'un sujet et
puis voyez on parle de ça je vois des
articles qui ne parlent que de ça et qui
ne parlent pas vous au moins vous avez
quand même parler des insecticides tueur
d'abeilles parce que ça c'est un
problème concret où là aussi il y avait
des gens qui voulaient qu'on ne fasse
rien et on a trouvé une voie pour le
faire en deux étapes 2018 2020 oui mais
on le fait ou et le cap est fixé les
industriels comme les agriculteurs
pourront pas dire annonce avait pas
d'accord avec cela mais c'est une très
belle relancer et vous verrez que dans
six mois ou dans un an on parlera plus
de cette histoire là en revanche on
parlera de tout ce qu'ils avaient dans
le projet de loi
on va parler maintenant des
manifestations et de la loi travail un
petit peu plus tard mais surtout de ces
manifestations en trois heures elle a
été interdite puis finalement elle a été
autorisée par l'exécutif sorte de
compromis ou d'un couac appelez ça comme
vous voulez le détail avec les à mundaka
va pas de volte face juste la volonté de
trouver jusqu'au dernier moment un
compromis avec les organisations
syndicales
voilà l'explication du premier ministre
tout a été fait monsieur chassaigne tout
du côté des pouvoirs publics c'est à
dire pour que les choses soient précises
du président la république du premier
ministre et du ministre de l'intérieur
ensemble pour permettre cette expression
démocratique qui peut sérieusement
croire que les droits syndicaux sont
bafoués dans notre pays
mais la droite interprète ce changement
de position de manière diamétralement
opposées on a l'impression finalement
d'un gouvernement qui navigue à vue
il ne sait pas où il va et qui n'a pas
de ligne directrice et
les français sont en train de subir cela
avec une fois manifestation une fois pas
manifestation si une grande partie des
députés socialistes se disent satisfaits
de cette sortie de crise la droite dite
absolument n'importe quoi nous n'avons
jamais rompu les discussions avec les
organisateurs et s'il accepte
aujourd'hui une solution que nous leur
avions proposé en tout cas que le
gouvernement leur avait proposé il ya
plusieurs jours c'est bien d'autres
regrettent la méthode utilisée par le
gouvernement
le gouvernement n'est pas là pour
autoriser ou pas autoriser les
manifestations
manifester est un droit fondamental et
donc je considère qu'en se mettant dans
une situation comme celle là
le gouvernement s'est trompé et
d'ailleurs il a corrigé son erreur le
gouvernement a d'ores et déjà prévenu
qu'aucun débordement ne sera tolérée si
des violences avaient lieu les
prochaines manifestations pourraient
être définitivement compromis pas de
ligne directrice navigue à vue on l'a
entendue dans ce reportage sur votre
sentiment également que mais là aussi
c'est des petites polémiques à la
surface des choses alors constituer un
enjeu de gironde un coup c'est interdit
finalement un coup ce nom mais ne
peuvent les brûle depuis le début la par
le tpiy est en jour mais oui mais de
l'autorié vu le gouvernement a dit qu'
il
le portrait est évidemment pas atteinte
au droit de manifester je vous rappelle
qu' on est en état d'urgence et que
depuis le début de l'état d'urgence
aucune manifestation n'a été interdite
si elle a eu une d'ailleurs c'était au
moment de la coop 21 parce que le
gouvernement avait dit on ne peut pas
être sur tous les fronts en même temps
juste après les attentats
bon en revanche les problèmes de
sécurité de violence le 14 juin
c'est quand même pas très vieux c'est à
peine plus d'une semaine
l'aca ont fait pas comme si on allait
oublier que l'on soit politique ou que
l'on soit dirigeant syndical ont fait
pas juste un petit communiqué de
condamnation pour se donner bonne
conscience et après on relance des
manifestations sont le terrain de jeu
c'est le terrain de jeu des gens
violents et le violon les locaux de la
cfdt saccagés hier vous qualifiez pas
comment vous et c'est intolérable
c'est pas la première fois
malheureusement nous dire ni pour la
cfdt ni pour le député que je suis en
parler d'autres sièges de partis mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que la question
de la sécurité du maintien de l'ordre en
manifestation elle est toujours là elle
était là hier elle est là aujourd'hui
elle sera là demain donc quel que soit
le gouvernement c'est pour ça que la
droite serait mieux d'être un peu
prudents et modestes parce qu'elle a
déjà été confronté à ce problème et si
elle revient au pouvoir elle sera
confrontée à ce qui s'est passé cette
séquence là c'est aussi un désaveu est
cinglant pour manuel valls
mais non on dit à un moment donné une
grande manifestation un parcours sur des
kilomètres et des kilomètres dans paris
autant de kilomètres
autant d'occasions de casse de gens qui
s'extrait de la manifestation up qui
vont commettre leurs agressions sont des
agressions contre des policiers ou des
destructions ou de bien et puis ensuite
hop et reviennent dans la maison dans la
manifestation comme ça on ne peut pas
évidemment les interpeller
par ailleurs il ya des manifestants qui
systématiquement s'interpose entre la
police et les violent lorsque la police
voudrait les interpeller donc on est
face à ce problème la barre ont dit on
va pas recommencer
alors on avait proposé un rassemblement
statique sur un lieu ça s'est déjà fait
les rassemblements et les organisations
syndicales n'ont pas voulu par un
compromis a été trouvé
c'est bien de trouver les compromis à la
ce qui permet de défendre le droit de
manifester est d'assurer la sécurité
concernant les casseurs vous parlez de
la cfdt tout à l'heure mais je veux
savoir comment vous qualifier ce qui
s'est passé et
ce coup ça peut aller avec moi je pense
qu'en plus ce ne sont pas simplement des
casseurs parce que les casseurs ça peut
donner l'impression que c'est des gens
qui viennent là en asie sans fil dans
une manifestation ils vont piller des
magasins
ils vont casser des vitrines ou tagués
un certain nombre de bâtiments comme
l'hôpital necker quand même loupé un
hôpital s'attaquer à un hôpital ce pas
qu'un symbole c'est une réalité il ya
des gens en raison uniquement sur les
réseaux oui mais ça mais c'est tout le
temps comme ça parce que ça c'est
politique
là il ya des gens et c'est pas les gens
de la cgt un jeu moi je dis pas ça c'est
plutôt la mouvance anarcho doute c'est
ultra elle
oui un arbitre à gauche qui a un projet
politique d'affrontement avec l'état
avec eux les organisations syndicales
qui sont dans la négociation ou avec les
partis politiques qui jouent le jeu de
la démocratie justement de cet objet de
la colère le projet de loi travail près
de quinze jours de débats au sénat et
une droite qui a largement remanié le
texte issu de l'assemblée le vote est
prévu mardi prochain julie et là une
deuxième semaine au sénat et des
tensions entre syndicats et gouvernement
qui se sont à nouveau invités dans les
débats mardi la présidente du groupe
communiste et bien à ça si affirme
qu'elle est prête à braver
l'interdiction de manifester dans le
même temps en séance son groupe dépose
un amendement pour défendre le principe
d' amnistie des faits commis dans un
cadre revendicatif une provocation pour
la droite mais loin des débats sans fin
de la première semaine
l'étude du texte s'est accéléré cette
semaine adoptée dans sa version modifiée
par la majorité
l'article 10 permettant aux syndicats
représentant seulement 30% des salariés
de valider un accord d'entreprise
en cas de blocage le patron pourrait lui
même organisé un référendum
mercredi le sénat a supprimé la
généralisation de la garantie jeunes
expérimentés depuis 2013
ce dispositif permet le versement d'une
allocation aux 16 points 5 ans en
situation de précarité
hier c'est l'un des points phares du
texte qui était abordé le cadre des
licenciements économiques pour les
motifs
le sénat a opté pour la baisse
d'activité d'au moins 30% pendant un
semestre par rapport à l'année passée
quant au périmètre géographique le
gouvernement il y avait renoncé
craignant des abus le sénat a
réintroduit la notion de périmètre
national
comme le souhaitait le medef enfin là
aussi le gouvernement avait reculé face
à la fronde des syndicats
le sénat a rétabli le plafonnement des
indemnités prud'homales en cas de
condamnation de l'employeur pour
licenciement abusif
les sénateurs devraient achever leur
travail dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi avant un vote solennel mardi
prochain à 16h voilà alors en réalité
les sénateurs ont effectivement écrit
leurs lois travail vote mardi au sénat
puis le texte sera de retour à
l'assemblée est ce que vous croyez
françois de rugy un compromis encore
possible ou est-ce que le 49 3 et déjà
acté un compromis avec qui parce qu'avec
la majorité sénatoriale là je crois que
c'est pas possible un mais cc c'est un
bon exercice et jeu derrière je salue le
votre initiative d'en présenter les
principaux éléments passe comme ça les
français au moins sont au parfum si je
peux aider à réflexion à la ainsi le
fera la droite le parti des républicains
si demain il a la majorité j'espère que
ça fait aussi réfléchir ceux qui
manifestent dans la rue
que les choses soient bien claires sur
voilà ce qui va se passer sur
l'alternance si jamais elle a lieu et en
l'occurrence c'est pas du tout
évidemment constructif 1 le but c'est
pas d'arriver à des compromis c'est pas
de faire avancer les choses
un ensemble et françois de rugy que
l'assemblée de sorte à l'assemblée
nationale mais vous savez il ya un
moment donné on a en face de nous des
gens qui contestent le texte et c'est
bien leur droit qui le contexte depuis
le début qui ont fait la politique de la
chaise vide quand il ya eu des
négociations parce qu'il y en a eu
le projet d'accord avant projet du
gouvernement et le projet qui a été
ensuite débattu à l'assemblée s'était
pas du tout de même pourquoi parce qu'il
y avait une négociation avec les
syndicats qui ont bien voulu jouer le
jeu de la négociation la cfdt l'unsa la
cftc la cfe cgc la cgt a refusé à fait
la politique de la chaise vide
après la 10 et le retrait ou rien
maintenant c'est plus le retrait du
texte mais c'est le retrait des
principaux articles
donc ça revient au même ce que cela
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible un
compromis possible sur l'article de
nauta mais qu'est ce que vous appelez un
compromis vous appelez le fait qu'on
retire l'article 2 panneaux non le texte
il a plus de chances donc moi je le dis
clairement pour moi la meilleure
l'article de c1 des articles plus
important parce que c'est ce qui permet
faut toujours redire ce qui alors que
c'est la négociation dans l'entreprise
ça c'est ont construit des compromis à
l'échelle les entreprises pas des
postures comme on en voit là à
l'assemblée au sénat où dans
la rue de gens qui ne veulent qu'on ne
touche à rien et qu'on le fasse rien 40
il ya sans doute un peu adaptés
permettent aux entreprises de s'adapter
entreprise par entreprise en un dialogue
entre is 49,3 ou pas vous vous dites oui
nos mais nous verrons bien mais c'est
probable si les frondeurs comme on dit
du parti socialiste sont toujours dans
la même optique et bien les mêmes causes
produiront les écologistes également aux
tiens vous le rappeler normal
à bas les légendes europe ecologie les
verts ils manifestent avec la cgt et fo
moi j'avais pas compris qu'il y avait un
axe politique pour l'écologie avec la
cgt et fo ils ont un peu de mal
d'ailleurs à l'expliquer is in dé
communiquer avec l'extrême gauche on
parle plus d'écologie à ça c'est sûr et
certain d'origine marc de boni est avec
nous c'est d'ailleurs de ce calme
bonjour monsieur du rugby jour je
voulais qu'on aborde l'autre référendum
de cette semaine celui de notre dame des
landes plus modestes comme enjeu mardi
21 juin dans libération que vous avez
signé une tribune dans laquelle vous
évoquez des erreurs commises par la
majorité des insuffisances des défauts
de pédagogie est-ce que la gestion de ce
dossier de notre dame de langue à la
mise en place un peu compliqué du
référendum en sont une illustration ce
qu'on a oui c'est sûr que la gestion de
ce dossier de ce problème parce que
c'est un problème elle n'a pas été très
bonne pendant quatre ans mais
aujourd'hui il y a une possibilité
justement de régler le problème avec le
référendum et c'était évident que si le
non l'emporté on est débarrassé du
problème et des problèmes qu'il ya
autour de ce projet
donc ça c'est une porte de sortie que
moi j'ai défendus que j'ai prôné auprès
du président du gouvernement et qui a
fini par être mise en place je m'en
félicite
il faut qu'ils aient le maximum
d'habitants de loire-atlantique qui
participent au vote dimanche prochain et
ça permettra d'en sortir j'en suis
convaincu vous n'êtes pas vraiment l'ami
des as 10 ans nous présente un peu comme
l'anti gauchistes de l'écologie j'avais
vu ça dans l'europe c'est ce que si le
non l'emporté c'est une victoire pour
eux les à dist ah bah non parce que les
indices eux c'est comme ceux qui
manifestent à paris là et qui cassent la
cfdt l'hôpital necker sont les bleus
août chez la même mouvance ces gens les
élections ça les intéresse pas le débat
démocratique c'est des méthodes
anti-démocratiques et donc si vous
voulez là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que depuis que le référendum a été lancé
on n'entend plus parler de ces gens là
c'est plus ces gens là qui sont qui vont
décider et c'est tant mieux
c'est les citoyens c'est des
associations qui elles agissent à visage
découvert qu'elle soit pour qu'elle soit
comptes des partis politiques des élus
chacun se positionne des citoyens mois
qui viennent me voir je vous dire par
exemple des gens de droite ils disent
mais moi je suis de droite
j'ai voté à droite aux dernières
élections je revins très à droite je
suis pas d'accord avec monsieur
retailleau par exemple qui dit qu'il est
pour le projet d'aéroport qui dit les
élections régionales c'est un référendum
à non parce que là c'est un référendum
un enjeu un vote et les gens quelle que
soit leur appartenance politique
ils pourront voter en conscience vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure le saccage de
votre permanence avait certainement des
existe parmi les gens qui est qu'ils ont
attaqué il ya de nombreux députés qui
sont dans votre cas quand le patron
d'adp et j'ai ici par l'assemblée d'un
climat de pré-guerre civile est ce que
ça vous parle
rossa je crois que c'est exagéré il faut
faire attention à ce que l'on dit parce
que heureusement nous ne sommes pas du
tout une guerre civile il faut pas
donner à une sur importance à ces gens
puissent aller à nantes on considère que
ces 200 300 personnes d'ailleurs quand
ils font des manifestations que d'entre
eux qui sont 200 300 et ils sont très
maîtrisée donc nous on n'en est pas là
en revanche oui la remontée d'une
certaine violence est quelque chose
qu'il faut combattre qu'il faut
condamner on parlait de la cfdt
moi je trouve quand même cas beaucoup de
leaders politiques de gauche ou de élevé
qui n'ont toujours pas condamné ces
actes par exemple et ça c'est grave
parce qu'il faudrait que quelles que
soient les violences d'où qu'elles
viennent et quel que soient les cibles
on les condamne
pourquoi nous la gauche la droite les
syndicats réformistes ou les autres
pourquoi ne crois même pas mais parce
que illzach association maintenant mais
ils ont l'impression que bas comme c'est
des gens qui sont plus éloignés de bain
on ne le fait pas mais ça peut passer
comme la justice ça peut pas être deux
poids et deux mesures alors autre sujet
pour terminer est ce que vous craignez
pas aux prochaines élections
législatives qu'on vous fasse payer
d'avoir voulu une écologie qui participe
au gouvernement qui participent à la
décision qui vous a amené à soutenir
mandant françois hollande et qui me le
ferait payer les électeurs il ya de
nombreux députés socialistes qui sont
inquiètes à mais écoutez quand on est un
démocrate et je le suis depuis toujours
et qu'on se présente aux élections on
accepte le verdict des urnes on cherche
à convaincre on défend moi je défendrai
le bilan de ce qui a été fait jeudi
aussi quand il ya des choses qui n'ont
pas été faites qui sont pas allés assez
loin le débat de la primaire permettra
aussi cela ce sera un moment où on
pourra mettre sur la table
expliquer parce que ceux qui ont passé
leur temps à critiquer on va aussi les
mettre devant leurs contradictions et
puis surtout on va leur demander qu'est
ce qu'ils proposent
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent pour l'avenir
là on a beau tendre l'oreille souvent on
entend rien comme coupable - autres
lignes directes et on vous serez
candidat ça me moi c'est l'écologie
l'écologie l'écologie ça c'est clair net
et précis je vais défendre l'écologie je
constate qu'à pas grand monde d'ailleurs
pour le faire donc nous on le fait au
sein d'une majorité parce que si on le
fait tout seul dans son petit coin ça
n'avance pas ça ne marche pas il sait
pas démocratique n'est plus que quand on
est démocrate ben on travaille avec
d'autres parce qu'on n'a pas la majorité
à soi tout seul
et moi si les électeurs ils tranchent
dans un sens ou dans l'autre de toute
façon si ça peut être frustrant
évidemment dans un cas c'est le verdict
normal des urnes il faut l'accepter
c'est comme le référendum britannique
moi j'aurais préféré les britanniques
restent dans l'union européenne
il faut un accepter le résultat de la
question alors avec cette primaire
justement à gauche c'est ce que votre
avis l'hypothèse cécile duflot candidate
définitivement enterrée au bo surnom
parce que je sens qu'elle elle veut être
candidate quoi qu'il arrive
mais le problème c'est candidats
pourquoi c'est ça qui compte pour peser
ou simplement pour des candidatures de
témoignage qui vont faire 1 2 3%
allez au premier tour d'élection
présidentielle mais vous en avez plein
vous avez monsieur la salle
il se présente pourquoi monsieur pu tout
madame arthaud messieurs cheminots il se
présente pourquoi ils ne servent à rien
pour passer à la télévision pendant cinq
semaines avant l'élection présidentielle
parce que il y aura l'égalité ou
l'équité des temps de parole c'est
l'élection présidentielle les français
d'ailleurs ne s'y trompe pas c'est
faible pour élire un président ou une
présidente de la république donc l'enjeu
ce sera qui peut être deuxième tour
est-ce que face au front national c'est
la droite où c'est la gauche cessera sa
mise en jeu et qui peut être président
de la république sera ça l'enjeu tout
pensé pouvoir faire mieux que cécile
duflot du coup que ces 3 % je pense que
dans une primaire ont peu pesé beaucoup
plus parce que on s'inscrit dans un
rassemblement pas au premier tour de la
primaire
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche
écologistes auront envie d'exprimer leur
sensibilité puisqu'ils savent qu'après
il ya un rassemblant regardée aux états
unis après la primaire aux états unis
vous avez vu hillary clinton bernie
sanders étaient pas des petites
divergences
le standard ce n'était même pas m'en
vouloir contenir tout n'est pas fini il
enlevait un débat quel très disputé mais
ils finissent par se rassembler mais une
fois que les
et citoyens etc les citoyens qui ont le
dernier mot je crois que dans la période
actuelle c'est vraiment important qu'on
se remette toujours sur le vote
démocratique de bonis merci beaucoup
vous remercie d'avoir été l'invité de
parlons là c'est donc la fin de cette
émission où on a parlé de largement de
ces référendum à la une en europe et
notamment du break site on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition de par le manque d'eau très
bonne ces deux programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires